un posible cambio radical para las
plataformas de contenidos en línea el
tribunal supremo de Estados Unidos
examina dos casos con enormes
implicaciones para el sector El primero
una demanda contra YouTube de Google por
los atentados terroristas de París de
noviembre de 2015 en la que la familia
de una de las víctimas acusa al sitio de
difundir propaganda de la autodenominado
estado islámico la segunda una demanda
similar contra Google facebook y Twitter
por un atentado terrorista en 2017 en
una discoteca de Estambul en el que
murieron 39 personas ambas ponen en tela
de juicio la sección 230 parte de la ley
de decencia en las comunicaciones de
1996 que establece que las plataformas
en línea que alojan contenidos generados
por los usuarios no sólo los editores de
esos contenidos y por tanto no son
legalmente responsables de ellos la
sección 230 también protege a las
plataformas de demandas cuando retiran
publicaciones los grupos del sector
afirman que las empresas se mueven en
una cuerda floja en lo que respecta a la
moderación de contenidos
si endurecemos las normas de
responsabilidad se obtienen dos
resultados potenciales uno es que los
servicios moderen filtren y desinfecten
en exceso sus contenidos para garantizar
que no haya riesgo potencial de
responsabilidad y el otro es que levante
las manos y apliquen de su
responsabilidad la ley es fundamental
para el modelo de negocio de las redes
sociales en el que los usuarios crean y
consumen contenidos gratuitamente
mientras que las plataformas se embolsan
los dólares de la publicidad tanto
demócratas como republicanos quieren
revisarla los demócratas afirman que los
algoritmos de recomendación alimentan la
radicalización y el odio enviando a
usuarios vulnerables a madrigueras de
desinformación y teorías conspirativas
los republicanos por su parte acusan a
las empresas de internet de izquierda de
bloquear los puntos de vista
conservadores